[Music]
how's it going everyone
this is International master Daniel
wrench this is chest comm and this is
everything you need to know about the
opening stage of a chess game before we
go any further you should know that this
video series was created for 90% of the
world's chess players those of you who
learned how the pieces move the relative
values of each respective chess man and
that the ultimate goal of the game is to
checkmate the enemy King but most people
never have an opportunity to learn even
the most basic strategies let alone
receive any insight into the higher
levels of chess understanding with this
video series we intend to help you
achieve just that most people never have
even a single lesson with a chess Pro
well the next four videos and the next
45 minutes are exactly that this is the
one chess lesson you need in your life
if you were only to get one buckle up
because over the next 45 minutes we are
gonna bring you the most fundamental and
vital chess knowledge that everyone
needs to succeed some grandmasters
secrets along the way as well as some
practical advice about how you might
bring this knowledge together in your
own games first up is going to be the
opening stage video which begins before
move 1 secondly we're gonna bring you
the middle game or tactics and strategy
video this might be one example of a
possible middle game position in the 3rd
video we're gonna move on to the final
stage of a chess game that being the
endgame and again this being an example
of a possible endgame and finally we're
gonna back up to show you two of the
greatest chess games of all time by some
of the best players in the history of
our game to show you how you might bring
it all together in a practical setting
let's jump right in the other exceptions
to this rule the opening is generally
considered to be complete when your
rooks are connected and so ignoring the
fact that this is obviously an
improbable position focus on the fact
that white is one move away from
completing his development by castling
to either side both moves would connect
the rooks
like all stages of a chess game there
are generally some principles and
guidelines to follow as far as how to
achieve your goals and so here we've
organized these principles for you to
follow and try to apply in your own
games the first three rules to the
opening develop develop develop why the
same rule over and over because it's
that important arguably the most
important piece of advice you're ever be
given is to use all of your pieces
whenever you play a chess game
development means to literally improve
your position by expanding it and both
sides will typically try to develop
their pieces as quickly as possible
making some random moves here to see
right now it's not so important where
you're bringing your pieces we're just
gonna try to show an example of how the
pieces might be brought out into the
game so that both sides might complete
their development and get castled the
basic idea here is that both sides have
completed their development by
connecting their rooks and they both
brought out their minor pieces first
which is usually the easiest way to
start fighting for control over a
position like this dream position shows
us the rule number four as far as how to
play the opening is to develop your
pieces toward the center this would be
an ideal example of how in a perfect
world if your opponent didn't challenge
your your development and your goal you
might develop your pieces to control the
most important area of the board why is
the center the most important area of
the board let's use the Knights as an
example
every piece typically does better in the
center than it does on the edge of the
board but the Knights in particular
really highlight this principle as we
can see here white's knight on e4 is
attacking or controlling depending on
how you look at it up to eight
territories whereas that a knight on the
corner is only attacking up to two
though this is an extreme example it
should hopefully display for you that
you would like to get every one of your
pieces in the center where they're on
their ideal squares if possible and so
now you've likely understand why we
would refer to this as a dream
development for white obviously both you
and your opponent will be fighting to do
so
as far as to attack the center so
achieving a dream position like that is
not completely practical let's go over a
couple different examples of how players
develop both sides trying to attack the
center here with the movie for expanding
opening up diagonals and attacking the
center black following suit with the
movie 5 trying to do the same white
develops a piece to put pressure on the
center and black now develops a piece to
defend the center there are many options
here at play including moves like Bishop
c4 which can lead toward a to Knights or
a Joko piano the move Bishop b5 which is
probably one of the most popular
openings in the history of chess that
bru Lopez as you can see by attacking
the knight we're indirectly increasing
our control over these two squares and
there's also the four Knights opening
which the moves have already been
displayed once earlier in this video
and now we'll describe it as such that
both sides are simply developing their
pieces they're minor pieces first which
is the best way to do it and they didn't
just develop their pieces to random
squares but rather try to bring them
toward the center with both sides
fighting for potential control over the
most important squares again why as we
reviewed every piece will have better
potential when in the center and you'll
notice that most mainline openings and
all grandmaster theory is contrived from
this principle develop develop develop
your pieces being the first three
principles and rule number four let's
develop them toward the center we're
halfway there
living on a prayer and don't you dare
change that channel our fifth rule goes
very well in conjunction with the first
four principles you've learned and that
is to never move a piece twice at least
not before move ten the basic idea
should be obvious if both players are
trying to fight as aggressively and
accurately as they can over the center
it doesn't make sense to try to ballet
your opponent's entire army with one
piece
for example let's focus on a Queen's
pawn game which unlike efore is slightly
more geared toward control the center
with the pawns after d5 by black usually
you'll see white follow up with a move
like c4 with the idea being that if
black already breaks the principle of
moving a piece twice he's given up
control over the center white will then
attack the center and we've already
learned the
the center if you remember earlier in
the video so there should be clear to
understand why this would be a nice
opportunity for white and after the pond
is recaptured pretty quickly
white is happy so rather than move a
piece twice black will develop another
pond into the center with either East
66th being the most popular options
choosing to defend the center rather
than to relinquish it by moving a piece
twice white will continue to develop
pieces with the same purpose of putting
pressure on this critical point trying
to induce black to move a piece twice
and therefore allow control over the
center good players will continue to
defend and as we see both players will
continue developing pieces once again
putting pressure on a piece that
indirectly puts pressure on these
critical squares and again rather than
moving the night away which in this case
would actually lose a large amount of
material as the knight is pinned to the
Queen
black will continue to develop pieces to
defend these critical points and you'll
notice after a few more moves of
developing neither side is considering
moving a piece twice but rather trying
to bring their pieces into the middle
part of the board and get castled as
quickly as possible
speaking of gasoline I'm about to hit
you with some big news
you ready principle number six is that
both players should be able to get their
kings castled get their Kings to safety
by the first 10 moves of every chess
game they play if not by the first 7
moves most mainline openings including
the Queens gambit declined that I just
showed you back up to let's say the Rui
Lopez an opening we've already displayed
you'll notice that even as early as move
for white is already prepared to castle
and black after developing his pieces
would not be too far behind from doing
the same thing perhaps defending upon
developing a piece and getting castled
the main purpose of this is not to show
you what is necessarily considered the
best theoretical moves at the highest
levels of chess but to show you that the
general principles can be followed and
very good positions can be achieved
before you even try to memorize opening
variations the four Knights another one
that we've reviewed you notice that both
sides brought their pieces out and
prepare to get castles once again we're
seeing both sides get castles here
before we've even reached move five
to move on hopefully the concept that
getting our king castle there's
obviously a good one is now clear let's
talk about principle number seven and
that is in regards to the first lady of
chess though I could likely give many
examples as to why it's not the best
idea to bring your queen out before the
minor pieces have been developed or
before you've been canceled I like to
give one particularly instructive one
this example occurs when one player the
white player in this case decides to
play for the form of checkmate something
that many amateur beginner players do
obviously if your opponent misses the
idea behind the Queen going backdoor on
the night and checkmating the King via
the week of square f7 then white is
successful but if black plays good moves
and white continues to be stubborn in
the attack of the weakest square
particularly with this mistake of g4
trying to remove the knight to achieve
the goal now we'll see why bringing the
Queen out so early was not the best idea
Black has the nice move d5 not only
putting an attack on the bishop but also
opening up his own Bishop to make a
threat on g4 and after captures 94 Queen
t1 we see a position where White has
moved the Queen four times including the
attack on the Queen and a move like 92
would fall prey to a very famous trick
of checkmate and any other move would
also leave white in a very bad position
now as we move on to our final three
principles it should be noted that the
first seven are the most important to
develop develop develop your pieces
bring them toward the center don't move
anybody twice and don't bring your queen
out too early when you combine those
ideas with the simple act of castling
you're pretty much on the right Road so
our final principles could probably be
considered advice and practical ideas as
to how you should transition into the
middle game as much as they should be
considered opening ideas for example our
eighth principle is to develop with a
purpose essentially what that means is
that all the mainline openings develop
moves with a purpose grabbing the center
purpose to attack the pawn purpose to
defend the pawn purpose to attack the
knighthood of
the pun that being the rule oppa's which
we already showed Queen's Gambit was
also an opening where you saw all the
moves centered around the critical
pressure of the center everybody was
involved in either the attack or defense
of these squares one way or another
those are two very famous examples of
openings that develop pieces with a
purpose and you should develop your
pieces with purpose in your own games
the ninth principle is to watch out for
your opponent's threats we can talk
about all these generalities but the
bottom line is if you go sit down for a
real game and your opponent brings the
Queen out early to attack the pawn you
might consider breaking the rule of
moving a piece twice in order to win a
large amount of material obviously
that's a silly example but the point is
to think about your opponent's threats
beyond your own goals and principles in
any position you play whether it be the
opening middle game or endgame stage
think about your opponent's moves and
develop your pieces with a purpose I
consider principles eight nine to go
hand-in-hand in that sense and you'll be
on the right track and finally our tenth
principle is in place basically to
remind you of all the things you've
learned in this video if you think about
it the tenth principle of connecter
Brooks is essentially an insurance
policy why because if you're in a
position to connect your Brooks whether
it be by castling or completing your
development with another piece by
definition that means that you've
achieved your goals of the opening you
followed all the principles of
developing your minor pieces attacking
the center hopefully bringing the Queen
out only when it was time and by finally
safeguarding the King and connecting the
Brooks you are ready to do battle in the
middle game in summary let's review the
principles you've learned in this video
today develop develop develop not a
single thing more needs to be set you
have to use your entire army in order
when chess games at any level control
the center this principle is in place to
remind you that your pieces are best
placed when they're in the middle of the
board where the action is don't move a
piece twice moving even a single minor
piece twice can steer you wrong and get
you away from achieving your goals of
developing all of your pieces you must
use your entire army castle early in
many cases you can even achieve this
before move
but certainly by move 10 you should be
castled in your king safe don't bring
the Queen out too early we saw an
interesting example as to why it's not
the best idea to use the first lady of
chess so early in the game remember this
and don't use the Queen early unless
completely necessary develop with a
purpose essentially your move should
have reason instead of just moving them
to random squares we saw in the ruh
Lopez in the Queens gambit that all
high-level openings all Grandmaster
ideas develop pieces with a plan and
with a purpose
think about your opponent moves and
threats obviously just bringing them out
to random squares wouldn't be a good
idea and nor would it be a good idea to
ignore your opponent's moves and threats
these principles are in place as
guidelines to help you in your own games
but you have to think about your
opponent's moves at the same time
connect the rooks the insurance policy
that's there to remind us if we've
connected the rooks than we followed all
these principles in this video and we
are ready to rock and roll everything
you need to know about the opening is
now complete we hope you enjoyed this
video and we will see you around on
chess calm
[Music]